hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
chapter four of one of them accuses
discourses is entitled in English on
progress or period or copays in Greek
the question then is what constitutes
progress in stoic philosophy which means
what constitutes progress towards our
human good for what it's fundamentally
best for us now Epictetus
is not you know departing from the
traditional stoic perspective and
talking about virtue and what virtue is
supposed to provide us he he tends to
use that term a little bit less than
some of the other stupid offers that we
can come across - because it tends to be
more focused on the nuts and bolts about
how we actually make our way towards
virtue but virtue is really going to be
the good verb for the stoic and virtue
is you might say the way in which our
rational faculty or our Faculty of
choice which we've seen are really in
many respects the same thing how they
are arranged what sort of condition they
are in
in accordance with nature out of
accordance of nature the specific
virtues you know of temperance or
justice or courage or wisdom there isn't
quite so much discussion about that here
it's just the generic conception of
virtue and weirdest epictetus getting
this wrong well in heard and this is one
of the key points about this in part by
having been taught stoicism from a
teacher who actually used books of
others no wicks and expounded on that
sort of thing but I'm also by putting it
into practice you might say
experientially and now experientially in
the sense of well I'm going to try it
once and then I'm done if it doesn't
work out for me because part of the very
doctrine of stoicism is that sort of
thing is not going to work because we
are partly screwed up when we start the
process so we're not in an adequate
position to fully appreciate what is
being taught in stoicism in an
experiential way until we start making
some progress now what's going on here
before he gets all the things that are
on the board
is a concern about what we could call a
disjunction between the theoretical
perspective in the practical perspective
between you know not necessarily book
smarts and street smarts because street
smarts and book smarts actually can
coincide but rather being able to not
only put things into practice but
recognize that the true test of this is
that we can put it into practice that is
our are grounds for for what
verification we're going to get it I
mean verification in the sense that
verification tests mean by it
but there's something more robust our
grounds for that are going to lie partly
in how we engage the world and partly in
how we
upon our own processes and whether we're
making progress so we need some sort of
goal you could say or touchstone and the
story is called that like several of the
other schools of antiquity did the sage
the wise person no souls right but they
didn't think of the sage primarily as a
totally disengaged figure up on the
mountaintop made a dispensing wisdom to
those who climb the mountain the same
would be somebody who you could see in
in the world actually living out the
stoic perspective they thought the
Socrates some of them thought at least
that Socrates was such a person you know
other people who look to two other
models some people look to epictetus
himself and what distinguishes the sage
it was not just having an intellectual
comportment or having a little arsenal
of ideas let alone having a well-stocked
library it was possessing and exercising
virtue behaving in a virtuous manner in
all circumstances a lot of people get
very caught up on wanting to have the
sage fully defined for them before they
can buy into this path Epictetus one
says it's a little bit of Curt before
the horse
you're not going to fully recognize one
of the sages until you're at least
partly on the way and you know how to
get pearly on the way not by worrying
about who the sage is or whether they
have existed or what their ideal
characteristics would be or anything
like that
because that's really a theoretical
exercise now he has some fun things to
say here about some people make the
mistake and I say this a lot adversity
myself I've been subject to it as well
thinking that progress in you know the
art of living the Art of Living Well is
somehow
I read and digested and perhaps you've
memorized it being able to try now
rotations from Chris's cruciferous was
one of the ancient stoic authors the
third scholar or leader of the school he
is probably one of the most prolific
authors of antiquity we have lost
practically everything that he's written
so we just have to take Epictetus word
for it and other stomachs that it was
really quite something to read but
reading books by themselves and thinking
about their content is not going to
automatically lead to practice as a
matter of fact it's not just that
meatiness observes this it's also
Aristotle it's also other people they
say the goal of the practical philosophy
is to do things in a certain way it's to
culminate in action and process so
heaven recognize precipitous not really
going to provide you the hallmark for
progress so he says when we need
knowledge virtue to be the thing of this
sort how comes it we we seek progress
and make a display of it in other things
what does the work of virtue serenity
who that is making progress the man has
read many treatises what is virtue nor
more than this to have gained a
knowledge of cruciferous now he's not
totally dismissing this as we're going
to see there is a great utility to
studying stoic philosophy but I'm
looking a little bit later on he's going
to I have another great example he says
you know if we talk to an athlete we say
show me your shoulders and then the
athlete could say well look at my
weights that I used to build those and
epictetus says I'm not interested in
those I'm interested in the effects of
those weights on your shoulders
show me your shoulders and so it's
similar to that take the treatise upon
choice so one of the things that you
know I've been written and see how
writing mastered it and epictetus says
that's not what I'm looking into but how
you
you're what how do you act in your
choices and refusals your horror May or
my plural and up or by your what you
choose to do then what you refrain from
doing right or reject your desires and
your aversions what are you actually
desiring what are you averse to you
might say well we can't really see
inside the person's head and know what
their desires and aversions are you can
see this doesn't think that's the case
at all we see the evidence of them in
how they react and we can ask them why
didn't you you know
why are you acting the way that you are
well I don't want that to happen to me
now we know about somebody's inversions
right so we can consult them how they
approach and use things or he's going to
say in other chapters how we use
appearances the fantasy I the things
that we encounter all of this provides
us with evidence whether somebody has
indeed taken a stoic perspective and is
following through in it in a practical
way not merely theoretical way so he
says show me whether you're acting in
harmony with nature or out of harmony
with it if you're acting in harmony
show me that but I will tell you you're
making progress but it's out of the
harmony then go away and don't confine
yourself to expounding your books but
why don't you go write some book
yourself you know you sort of say self
help person write your own book it only
matters if you can put it into real
practice and if you can do so
consistently so what else does this mean
he says a little bit later huh it means
the person is making progress withdraws
themselves from externals that doesn't
mean that they disengage themselves or
the world and you know shut themselves
up in a basement apartment and never
come out and unless it's late at night
then nobody's around no what it means is
that they do not place their desires and
aversion
out there attached to things in the
world they focus on what's within namely
their pro erases their Faculty of choice
translated also is moral purpose they
begin to examine their reasoning about
things not just in you know general and
not just some theoretical terms but in
very practical terms they begin to look
at themselves they begin to take stock
of their habits and their you know ways
in which they react in a knee-jerk
fashion to see whether there's something
that that needs to be changed there
something that needs to be examined
there they engage in the sort of thing
that other traditions of moral
philosophy and other practices like say
spiritual direction or psychoanalysis or
you know pick whatever you like and also
engaged in looking to see what really
makes us behave the way that we do and
whether we have some control over it
whether we can shape and reshape it
through some judicious decisions about
it so that we can actually start going
towards the goal that we want which is
virtue and tranquility a kind of
security that we can we can possess
where the outside world and what's
happening with it and all the crazy
people in it aren't going to get to us
and and bother us because we focused on
what really is in our control he talks
about working upon the term is X area
side and that means to you know sort of
like an arrogant it is in fact of work
right so when you go to work and you
work on something it doesn't necessarily
have to be you know hammering something
I've been doing a spreadsheet a lesson
plan shooting a video you are working
right now imagine that you're not
working on external things but you're
actually working upon
yourself not saying things that just
make you feel good for a moment but
really taking stock of what your
situation is and then doing the sort of
things that would be required to to
perfect to bring there we go
to bring your prior ASIS your Faculty of
choice that whole complex of designers
aversions belief saw that into
accordance with nature or is able to
also say this so it's to harmonize some
phone name with nature nature not
meaning just doing what comes naturally
to you or you know looking at the you
know you so see Natural Science Research
or evolutionary biology or any of those
sorts of things those well by the way
the dock boxes systems of Dharma
according to have picked you this may be
up to you whether you want to
incorporate those or not you know if you
think that those are automatically
binding on you because you read
something in science which may in fact
be confuted later on you know that would
be your choice ultimately but that's not
only means by nature you means fully
developed human nature and we have a
choice about whether we want to develop
ourselves along those ways if we want to
make progress or not so is there any
utility than to say reading cruciferous
there is and this is very important to
point out because I don't want to give
you the impression that stoicism means
saying let's throw the book away and
just to cook we wanna do it right he
says what then does cruciferous furnish
us well then you may know that these
things are not false from which serenity
arises and tranquility comes to us take
my books and you shall know how
conformable and harmonious with nature
and the things which render me tranquil
he says oh great good fortune
all the great benefactor who points the
way so you know we shouldn't think that
cruciferous is a great
I and if we in fact had his books we
made ourselves having books we should
redo them well we shouldn't mistake
actually reading those things and
sitting there thinking about them with
the putting them into action that those
books
what are we to take them seriously in
the way that we ought to would require
us to do we can say the same thing about
that 14 is this book it's one thing to
have the theoretical understanding of
the system and how it all fits in
together what's that you know what's a
pro I racist and let's all they obsess
about these technical terms it's a whole
different thing and trust me much much
harder to actually put this into
practice and follow through on it but
you really only fully understand the
philosophy for the Stoics when you are
in the process of making progress so the
theoretical understanding is in certain
respects dependent on a practical
understanding because that's where the
art of living lies